that's yeah I get that uh what you know
there's certain artists um
correct me if I'm wrong but you and Jay
never did anything together no me and
Jay don't work together was there ever
just crazy it is crazy it's not like
even me I'm like how I've worked with
every artist in the globe except Jay-Z
until this day I don't know why it never
got close to happening it never was even
inquired wow because the thing is I
think I think it was the the timing in
each other's careers because at the time
when I was in at Peak musically and
moving some way he was moving to the
executive side executive right Def Jam
and I think it was that timing at the
moment when I'm going this way he's
going this way yeah he'd rather have you
do a record for one of his artists right
I think yeah yeah because at that time I
was producing records for Def Jam and
all that I even got to the point where
my brother was in Def Jam at the same
time so it was like I think it was but I
don't until his day I never understood
why that never happened yeah I mean
because yeah you got records with
everybody else right [ __ ] I never
understood that yeah